further this self quoi app yourself
identical knowing is the absolute
universal so that justice knowing as its
own knowing is conviction is dooty dooty
is no longer the universal that stands
over against the self on the contrary it
has known to have no validity when thus
separated it is now the law that exists
for the sake of the self not the self
that exists for the sake of the law law
and duty however have for that reason
the significance not only of being for
self but also have intrinsic being for
this knowing because it is self
identical is precisely the in itself in
consciousness to this in itself
separates itself from that immediate
unity with being for self as thus
standing over against the latter it is
being a being for another duty itself as
Duty forsaken by the self is now known
to be only a moment from signifying the
absolute essence it has fallen to the
level of mere being which is not self is
not for itself and is therefore a being
for another but the being for another
remains an essential moment just because
the self qua consciousness constitutes
the antithesis of being for self and
being for another and now Duty is
present in consciousness as something
directly actual is no longer merely
abstract pure consciousness
here now in paragraph 639 we are seeing
an important turning point in the
development of the moral consciousness
and this is a development you could say
not with grasping some some absolutely
new idea but with a shift in how the
moral consciousness is understanding
itself in relation to the one thing it's
been completely centered around morality
or if you like duty flicked right and
Hegel starts this paragraph out by
saying this self as a pure self
identical knowing is the absolute
universal so that justice knowing as its
own knowledge as conviction is in fact
Duty and conviction being convinced you
Birdseye gone right so we're talking
about something here that isn't purely
theoretical but is inherently practical
this knowing is a knowing of itself as a
moral being as an agent as something
that has agency as something that could
do the right thing or do the wrong thing
but is recognizing some sort of duty and
Hegel wants to stress here that at this
point as we've seen in the previous
period paragraphs the self is now being
viewed as what is really universal
before it was duty and the self was
particular or it might be something
that's not really a self but a self
projected as the universal into the
beyond now we actually have the
self-grasping itself as conscience give
its it right and so what was duty with a
capital D all capital letters has been
revealed as something that we actually
projected out there and now can
recuperate back into our selves there's
a sigelei emotion of estrangement
or alienation and tandang and then a
reconciliation that takes place within
the Hegelian dialectic so the self is a
pure self identical knowing right self
identical doesn't mean that it's it's
some sort of tautology or some you know
navel-gazing turned in on itself it's
actually trying to figure out where does
it fit into the world and how does the
world fit into it there's a little bit
more to the story but we're gonna see
this arise in the next paragraph even
more so he says that justice knowing as
its own knowing as conviction as uber
toy gun is duty clicked right duty he
says now is no longer the universal that
stood over against the self it's known
to have no validity when separated okay
so when was it separated when we found
that we ourselves could not possibly
live up to the duty when we're dealing
with all these paradoxes or antinomies
or antithesis between happiness and
morality or you know the nature and and
our inclinations and desires and what a
whole you know pure completely realized
will would look like but it couldn't be
realized it could only be ideal all of
those sorts of things we've now moved
past that and with that this notion of
Duty has been if not simply canceled out
transcended in a way alcohol burn right
so at first we are considering it as
absolute essence he says it's now the
law that exists for the sake of the self
not the self that exists for the sake of
the law a very important reversal has
happened here lawn duty he says have for
that reason the significance not only of
being for self but also of intrinsic
that is being in itself you know on Zeke
sign as opposed to her Zeke sign and you
know when we're in the Hegelian
dialectic we're always attentive to this
being in itself being for itself and we
want to put the two of them together get
something that is being in and for
itself
that's always what we're aiming at so it
sounds as if law and duty insofar as
they fall within the scope of the self
or conscience all right now are able to
have that sort of status but that's not
really the case
he says law and duty have the
significance not only of being for self
but also have intrinsic being why for
this knowing because it is self
identical is precisely the in itself so
the self is already the being in itself
and in a certain way duty is being
evacuated you could say drained of its
transcendental status or you could say
it's being brought along and put under
the heading of the self brought within
its ambit so he goes on and he says in
consciousness this in itself separates
itself from this immediate unity with
being for self so the immediate unity
here is the being for self this kind of
circular relation I know who I am
because I think about myself and I am
convinced I have you know this this
conscience you listen I have a you know
a knowledge a vision of myself Who I am
I'm aware of myself as a moral agent I'm
aware of myself as the one who
recognizes duty or could choose not to
recognize duty or exists in relation to
duty which is not something coming from
some heavenly being imposed on me like
some sort of stamp or cookie cutter that
I'd better wiggle my way
in two but rather something that I now
recognize have been bringing to the
world and and when we do this when we
recognize how much of a role that we
ourselves play in morality there is that
temptation of saying well it's all up to
us the hell with it we don't have to
follow any duties we can make of this
whatever we want or we could you know
succumb to one of the early
enlightenment dreams well if there's no
God and heaven above we can make earth a
heaven and oftentimes we make it a hell
because of that Hegel has a by the way
and this is a bit of an aside a very
ambivalent relationship with the
Enlightenment you can say he thinks it
hasn't gone far enough it wasn't self
conscious enough it didn't take into
account its own development so a naive
conception of enlightenment as just
leaving those stupid people of faith
behind and substituting science in its
wake
that's not going to cut it for somebody
like Hegel that would be a science of
the understanding but not of fair known
reason or because if the concept that
would be a science of the understanding
which operates in terms merely of
picture language I realize we're going a
little bit outside of the text here but
it's it's useful context I think so he
goes on and he says duty itself as Duty
forsaken by the self is now known only
to be a moment from signifying the
absolute essence what it was signifying
before it has fallen to the level of
mere being which is not self is not for
itself and therefore is being for
another being in itself at this point in
time doesn't get you much instead it's
rather being for another and the
dialectic here is going to be between
being for itself and being for another
so he says the being for another remains
an essential moment just because the
self as consciousness
constitutes here is translated as
antithesis
Gagan Zots constitutes the antithesis of
being for self and being for another and
now what is duty present in
consciousness as duty is present in
consciousness as something directly
actual and is no longer merely abstract
self-consciousness as it was in the
previous conception of duty that we are
working with before so we have an
advanced being made here and something
new is going to be brought on the scene
or rather brought back to the scene in
the next paragraph
this being for another is therefore the
substance which remains in itself or
unexploited which is distinct from the
self-conscious is not given up pure duty
or the abstract in itself Duty is the
essential moment of relating itself qua
universality to another conscience is
the common element of the two self
consciousnesses and this element is the
substance in which the deed has an
enduring reality the moment of being
recognized and acknowledged by others
the moral consciousness does not possess
this moment of recognition by others of
pure consciousness which has a real
existence and consequently does not act
or actualize anything at all it's in
itself is for it either abstract unreal
essence or being as a reality which is
not spiritual the existent reality of
conscience however is one which is a
self an existence which is conscious of
itself the spiritual element of being
recognized and acknowledged the action
is thus only the translation of its
individual content into the objective
element in which it is universal and
recognized and it is just the fact that
it is recognized that makes the deed a
reality the deed is recognized and
thereby made real because the existent
reality is directly linked with
conviction or knowledge or in other
words knowing one's purpose is directly
the element of existence is universal
recognition for the essence of the
action duty consists in consciences
conviction about it it is just this
conviction that is the in itself it is
the implicitly universal self
consciousness or the state of being
recognized and hence a reality what is
done with a conviction of Duty is
therefore it wants something that is
standing and a real existence there is
then no more talk of good intentions
coming to nothing or of the good man
fearing badly on the contrary the duty
that is known to be such is fulfilled
and becomes a reality just because what
is essentially a duty is the universal
for all self consciousness is that which
is recognized and acknowledged and the
positively is but taken separately and
alone without the content of self duty
is a being for another something
transparent which has merely the
significance of an essential tea in
general lacking all content
paragraph 640 now brings the turning
point
past the turning point you could say
what was going to be a sort of pivot
this distinction between the for itself
and the for another and how self and
duty are connected brings in the other
and this is a term that we've seen is
very important in Hegel consciousness is
always related to some sort of other but
what makes consciousness human
consciousness really what it is is that
it's not only related to an other as in
you know pieces of chalk or objects
things that we can perceive but it's
related to another consciousness another
self-consciousness we saw this with the
beginning of the self consciousness
section going through the master-slave
dialectic stoicism skepticism unhappy
consciousness the reasons section and
all sorts of other parts of spirit and
once again the other is brought into
play in this long paragraph why because
self consciousness which is what human
spirit really is Geist mind can never
truly get away from the other and the
question is how is it going to not exist
solely alienated from the other or fused
and identified with the other or
subordinated to the other or
subordinating the other but in some sort
of more productive integrated
relationship and that is what morality
and Duty is in some way always on the
cusp of right we can think of this is a
little bit of a digression before we go
into this particular passage but think
of the the interplay that's been going
on for the most part in the previous
sections of this morality portion of
spirit it's been going back and forth in
a rather individualistic way or where
the individual is the universal right
hasn't really engaged with other people
so much a little bit in the you know
self-deception ORD assemblance part i
suppose you could say but it really
could just be fooling itself here in
this paragraph we now have not only
another consciousness coming in another
self-consciousness we have what was
really central what did it what it was
that self-consciousness was looking for
what was the object of its hunger or
desire its bagheera recognition on air
kenan once again that becomes the
central motif and that's not a dance
that you can do on your own
right you can look in mirrors as much as
you like the way people do in the gym or
when they're dancing by themselves I
suppose you could do it with like a
video screen and you're watching
yourself oh this is so great I look so
wonderful it's not the same thing as
having somebody else looking at you is
it another who you don't control who you
might want to try to control but whom
you're looking for some sort of
recognition from so let's take a look at
this he says the being for another is
therefore the substance that remains in
itself or unexploited which is distinct
from the self so before we had the self
as including being for self and being
for another and now there's a split
that's taking place it turns out that
the being for another is something
that's attaining its own sort of
substance before it was just sort of you
know an afterthought or a part of a
antithesis a Gagan Zots in the previous
paragraph now it's taking on its own
life so he says conscience has not given
up your duty or the abstract in itself
duty is here's a wonderful line the
essential moment of relating itself qua
universality to another what does that
mean
Duty is let's let's leave the
universality out of it Duty is this
relating oneself to another the duties
that I have I have not as Robinson
Caruso all by myself on a desert island
actually Robinson Crusoe is not really
by himself he has all the artifacts of
humanity with him he is bringing his
culture to the island he winds up you
know finding hostile people and also an
native person who he calls Friday right
so Robinson Crusoe is kind of a made-up
not even a he's a fictitious example but
even as a fictitious example he's made
up he doesn't illustrate the person
totally on their own right he actually
does exist in relations to others he
thinks that he should keep track of time
for example well why the hell should he
do that is there some duty to the self
well he thinks that he should you know
he's bound to something and he can't
quite articulate what it is he should
also put aside provisions you know which
makes it kind of a boring book well I
took these grapes and turned them into
raisins and then I did this that's
that's a lot of Robinson Caruso consists
in why why should he do any of that sort
of stuff what duty is there in that well
there's a relation to the other even if
the other is not right there so he says
duty is the essential moment of relating
itself to another
now notice qua universality qua
allgemeine height we are universalities
as well as specific individuals as well
as individuality itself i ghen height
we're also universal the fact that
you're hearing me communicate to you
doesn't mean that we just have a
universal medium that were you know
using right now though the language
English for example and all the
conceptions that go along with that
English is in me English is in you the
here or if it's being translated within
the translator right who knows what'll
happen with it with these commentaries
Lee
on perhaps there'll be some sort of
algorithm that we can put them through
and then that's other universalities
being sort of collapsed into each other
so let's let's go on
he says conscience dissing is the common
element notice what he says here of the
two self-consciousness now he's not just
talking about self another he's talking
about self consciousness another self
consciousness you might say whoa oh we
better watch out for this we know where
this goes off to the master-slave
dialectic right the two consciousnesses
are gonna run into each other no that's
not gonna happen because we are so far
beyond the struggle to the death and
that primitive master-slave dialectic
this is a little bit of a digression
there's so many people that want to
reduce Hegel to the master-slave
dialectic that was a the key idea that
he had nonsense
that's it's exactly the opposite of that
that's why it's early on in the book and
that's why people gravitate to it
because it's easy to wrap their heads
around know the human development that
has taken place means that although we
can find relations that are like the
master-slave dialectic those are deviant
those are not where the the dialectic is
actually developing that's not where the
initiative of world spirit developing
itself through all of these people
that's not where it is or where it's
going we've advanced to a certain point
now we have self-consciousness as who
can relate to each other in different
ways and if you remember back to the
self consciousness section that was the
great desire was it not can't we have
something that goes beyond this stupid
play of power and gives us genuine
morality real relations to the other
real good relations to the other you
might say power is real so he says
conscience is the element of the common
element of the to self consciousness is
this element is the substance in which
the deed has an enduring reality the
deed is the top right the doing the
thing that we we accomplish it has an
enduring reality what is
it's enduring reality here's where it
gets really interesting what gives our
actions genuine meaning the the meaning
that we ascribe to them maybe if we're
totally narcissistic that's right but
even then we want other people to like
you know oh you're so wonderful you know
you matter so much you're you're the
best in the world right it's recognition
by others that we want and here the the
translation can be a little bit
misleading just because of the way that
that Miller chose to articulate it
I wrote a few of the German terms down
here so we can take a look at him he
says the the deed has an enduring
reality in what the moment of being
recognized and acknowledged by others
now the the recognition and
acknowledgement you know lexically it
sounds like they're two different things
they're the same thing
they're on air cannon that's the verb
for it well of the verbal form right the
noun that's made from from the verb that
means recognition that means
acknowledgement those are the same in
this and Hegel uses another really
interesting formulation here on your
Conte Deardon Fong de nonlin all right
so by literally from but by the other
being recognized being acknowledged by
the other but notice that it's not just
being viadon right there is this
passivity to it but there's also this
sense of Futurity to it in the word
itself especially when you're
contrasting it against the other way
that Hegel's talking here on aircon sign
being recognized becoming recognized
there is a temper ality that's involved
here in a rather suggestive way
I don't just want to be recognized now
oh and I don't want my deeds just
recognized now I want them to be
recognized going forward into the future
I want them to become something that
will be recognized so there's you know
be sort of at the lexical level there's
some really interesting stuff going on
here that's not being captured by the
translation that I just wanted to clue
you into so he says the moral
consciousness does not possess this
moment of recognition on are consigned
by others of pure consciousness which
has a real existence and consequently it
doesn't act when we don't have
recognition we may engage in actions but
we don't really act because it's not
being retained it's not being recognized
as not being acknowledged and and here
let's pause for a second think of the
condition of so many people who are
treated as non people and one of the
ways that happens is saying well
whatever you do we don't care it doesn't
matter you don't matter that's the
opposite of recognition
you're a non person you have being mere
being but you don't have real being
you're not a visa something essential
right
you're a sign so he goes on and he says
here we go it's in itself is for it
either abstract unreal essence or being
as a reality which is not spiritual and
this is this is one of the problems we
can fall into now what else can we have
he says the action is thus only the
translation of the individual content
and to the objective element in which it
is universal and recognize this is where
we would actually have recognition let
me read that again the action the Han
lung is only the translation of its
individual content what it is that we
bring to it into this objective element
in which it is universal the individual
becomes universal right this is an
important transition we're able to
recognize what we're doing is not just
being our action but being an action of
a certain sort or an action that certain
kinds of people do that it has meaning
to it just naming it by itself is
already bringing a universal to our
action so he says it's it's universal
and recognized on account and it is just
the fact that it is recognized
that makes the deed the doing the taught
a reality of your Creek Heights so he
says the deed is recognized and thereby
made real why because the existent
reality is linked with conviction abodes
eigem or knowledge it's made practical
in a sense that more than one
self-consciousness can grasp
we couldn't grasp it through a variety
of different modes we could grasp it
through both of us saying aha I agree
with you that this is what is being done
it could also be grasped through
conflict when we're saying I'm doing
this and the other person saying no no
you're not doing that you're doing this
instead but insofar as we can actually
argue with each other we're
acknowledging each other in a certain
way right okay let me actually go into
another digression there's nothing more
pathetic than all of these people who
are you know engaging in the debate me
bro or you're a coward sort of thing
they they so badly crave recognition in
a Hegelian aspect they are
self-consciousness that needs to be
acknowledged by another
self-consciousness and doesn't quite
know how to get that other than getting
all aggressive and trying to you know
say I've I've got the facts on my side
or you know your your arguments not a
good argument or whatever it is that
they're doing they will never get what
they want this is why they're always on
the make so to speak that way all right
all right let's go on so he says the
deed is recognized made real because he
exists
reality is directly linked with
conviction or knowledge or in other
words knowing one's purpose one's goal
is directly the element of existence is
universal recognition now notice what he
brings in their Universal recognition no
longer just the recognition of one
self-consciousness by another but a
broader recognition where somehow in the
society we'd all be recognizing each
other that's not going to actually be
attained at this point but that's
something that we're aiming at right
that's way down the line in the very end
of this this work so he says the essence
of the action duty consists in
conscience conviction about it what is
the conviction says it's just this
conviction that is the in itself it is
the implicitly universal
self-consciousness when we have a
conscience an individual conscience and
it is telling us this is what you need
to do this is the right thing this is
the wrong thing you know we we frame it
in a lot of others a little voice inside
of me talking or it's the voice of God
implanted in me or it's the angel on my
shoulder as opposed to the devil on my
shoulder or you know now this the the
modern-day Stoics have started having
the siege on your shoulder Socrates or
epictetus talking to you however you
want to frame it
it's another and it's supposed to be
universal it's not just supposed to be a
single author who could be say corrupted
or something like that so it's not like
you know in Family Guy for example where
Peter Griffin has a Peter angel and a
Peter devil and they're both idiots like
he is hey no it's something more
Universal than than that
so he says here we go this conviction
that is the in itself it's the
implicitly universal self conscious or
the state of being recognized and hence
a reality what is done with the
conviction of Duty is therefore at once
something that has standing and a real
existence
now this is this is getting a little bit
ahead of ourselves as we're gonna see
but this is you know Hagel doing his
usual stick spirit advances this sounds
really good let's see where we're going
right so he says there is then no more
talk of good intentions coming to
nothing right or of the good man faring
badly why not well because it turns out
that there actually is a connection
between say virtue or morality and
happiness or doing well within this
world and the juncture is conscience and
not just your conscience but the
conscience of other people who are like
yeah that guy's you know or that that
that person over there is actually doing
the right thing let's treat them the way
they ought to be let's recognize them
let's say that they are a good person
then we could frame this in all sorts of
ways it could be you know let's let's
fund their their campaign let's you know
put them in the newspaper let's give
them an award let's actually pitch in
and help out with their project but
there's some sort of recognition here
and that makes it possible for the
action the moral action to become a
genuine reality something that wasn't
happening before so he says the duty
that is known to be such is fulfilled
brought to fruition and becomes a
reality just because what is essentially
a duty is the universal for who for me
no for all self-consciousness as Hegel
says in actually recognizing how I ought
to behave and this is a admittedly quite
ideal I'm setting down a pattern for all
self-consciousness isn't that wonderful
so he goes on he says this is what is
recognized and acknowledged and thus
positively is notice to be recognized is
to have being to be given more being why
because
we're social creatures because what we
say and not just what we do actually
matters and what other people think and
say and believe also matters this of
course makes us vulnerable to our own
foolishness or to their own jackassery
in getting things wrong they there's no
guarantee that they're actually going to
embody Universal self-consciousness
particularly well or morality you can
behave as a moral agent and have a whole
bunch of people around you who say well
why did you do that that doesn't pay off
well you're stupid or are all sorts of
things along those lines that we see
many examples of that so he goes on he
says taken separately and alone without
the content itself duty is a being for
another something transparent which has
merely the significance of an essential
T in general lacking all content if we
want duty to make sense at this point it
has to be the duty of people who exist
in relation to each other and who give
each other recognition or
acknowledgement
you